good morning heck it's tuesday but it's
not just any tuesday it's my birthday
and today for my birthday i am giving
myself an old-fashioned parts video
that's right hank today's video is like
bosch's garden of earthly delights it
comes to you in three semi-connected
parts part one the final maybe episode
of my podcast the anthropocene reviewed
comes out on thursday it is about this
drawing which was sketched by the
cosmonaut alexey leonov in march of 1965
shortly after he very narrowly survived
the first spacewalk there is video of
this first ever spacewalk on youtube and
i like to watch it whenever my palms are
really dry and in need of some sweat
leonov's life was fascinating but mostly
the podcast is about why we make art and
what we give up to make it it's been
three months now since the anthropocene
reviewed book was first published and it
has been strange and lovely and
terrifying to share something so
personal and i didn't know how to write
about that directly so i wrote about
space art working on the anthropocene
reviewed has been an incredible
experience but i i think i'm ready to go
back to
writing fiction maybe i was a long pause
before i said writing fiction
part two good news from the hank and
john chatbot hank in your last video you
had an ai based on us answer questions
from our viewers and that was only like
moderately dystopian so i decided to try
it out for myself i said hey it's john
and it responded beth and mom and dad
have said because we don't know yet that
i'm probably going to live more than and
i was like wait i'm probably going to
live more than what because you know
mortality is always on my mind hank but
especially on my birthdays and it
responded i'm guessing 1 million years
but i could be off by quite a bit now
initially hank i thought this was
unambiguously good news like assuming
the chatbot knows more than i do a
million year life expectancy ain't bad
but then i was thrown into a new
existential quandary do i really want to
live for a million years i mean modern
humans have only been a thing for 250
000 years and i feel like just living
through all of human history so far
would be extremely exhausting and even
after all of that i would only be to one
quarter of my life span anyway it all
got me to thinking about what my
preferred lifespan actually would be and
today on my 44th birthday i would like
to announce that my preferred life span
is officially 97. it's a nice solid
prime number and i feel like rooting for
triple digits would be a little bit
gauche so there we have it i would like
to live to be 97 you nothing happens if
you don't make goals in this world part
three adulthood when i was younger i
thought of adulthood as a kind of zombie
apocalypse like my job was to stave off
adulthood for as long as possible
running from it fighting it off at every
corner knowing all the while that i
would inevitably succumb to adulthood
and become part of the zombie horde it
seemed to me that people who had
contracted adulthood devoted their lives
to thinking about
excruciatingly boring stuff like lawn
maintenance and life insurance and
whether the chrysler pacifica minivan is
superior to the honda odyssey minivan
and i was horrified by all that and did
not want to become a proper adult i
think deep down what terrified me about
proper adulthood was that it seemed like
changelessness to me like i remember
being a kid and looking at my dad's
shoes and thinking
those shoes are like 10 years old and
they still fit but it turns out that one
a change in shoe size is not the most
important or interesting change that
humans go through and two there is a
comfort and pleasure to ten-year-old
shoes that literally cannot be imagined
by people whose shoe size changes every
year and more importantly three
adulthood turns out to be full of change
like yeah i have a lot of the same
relationships i had 20 years ago but
those relationships have dramatically
changed and deepened across the decades
and personalities changed too like as a
30 year old i hated gardening and
exercise and being outside and i didn't
care one wit about third tier english
football and now i love all that stuff
and 15 years from now hopefully i will
be different again so here's to that
hope and to life just not a million
years of it hank i'll see you on friday